hey guys welcome back to the evident
caitlyn podcast the podcast where we are
asking the questions just the only
questions you need asked and answered
mainly Caitlin's gonna be interviewing
me cuz I got an interview you and we
ended up taking the whole podcast
episode just on that one really awesome
question that I'd like thought long and
hard about pretty more question if you
missed it asked me about editing but
Before we jump into like the main topic
I just have a mini topic I don't know
where it's gonna fit other than this but
this just like blew my mind guys did you
know I'm guessing not because it's like
a secret and that's the point of me
exposing it because it's a secret but
did you know that Twitter has a secret
secret back-end where you can upload
long videos you can add like
call-to-action links you can add a title
description you can choose the thumbnail
you can use Twitter like YouTube right
but they don't tell you that they don't
show you that and how you get access to
it is you have to sign up for Twitter
ads account which sounds kind of scary
it's like well I don't want to I don't
want to spend money on ads on Twitter
and and you not only have to sign up for
the ads account you also have to add
your credit card also scary and as soon
as you've added your credit card to your
Twitter ads account they now allow you
to upload longer videos with thumbnails
title descriptions call to actions like
fancy things yeah and they're like
unlocks this like great level of
functionality that I feel like most
people might want especially fellow
content creators most most people would
really want all of those features but it
just makes it really secretive
I almost it's so yeah that's weird it's
like I think actually this the fact that
it's a secret isn't so weird the fact
that you can do it without paying for
anything that's so weird or for me
because it seems like something that
should be it's just like for anyone who
cares enough to research it google it
try it you can use it but anyone else no
no no no it's crazy it's crazy okay I
haven't seen any like I mean we follow a
bunch of content creators and you know
content creators and like businesses and
stuff I haven't seen anyone do it no
crazy get excited about like anything
that feels like a social media hack yeah
such a can and I'm doing it on like not
all of our Twitter accounts but oh yeah
did you guys know that we have three
Twitter accounts Evan and Caitlin Evan
Caitlin game Evan Caitlin podcasts I'm
not sure with my podcast one it's don't
quote me on that it might be like Evan
Caitlin pod yeah anyways moving on to
the main topic
Caitlin has some scintillating
scintillating would wait alright so
sorry
we interrupt this regularly scheduled
program scintillating means sparkling or
shining brightly okay brilliant or
excitingly clever or skillful are you
prepared yes okay so last time you asked
me about one of my main responsibilities
other things that takes up most of my
time for the work that we do and that
was editing so I wanted to ask you about
the stuff that you do and so I got a
interesting place with to start would be
what's one of the most difficult tasks
that you do that I might underestimate
or not see the full picture of or maybe
like that the audience doesn't fully
understand difficult or time-consuming
because I think those are kind of two
different things I think that the most
difficult thing both of us do that not
much of the audience sees is like what
video are we doing like that's the most
difficult and most important thing that
we do and we do put a lot of time and
thought and energy into that but I think
that's something that both of us know so
so you specifically asked something that
you may not know
and that kind of reminds me I'm not sure
if this is my final answer so give me a
little bit of time to like process be a
stream of consciousness as all of our
podcasts usually are but we were going
for a walk the other day and we are
talking about our content in general and
what was fun and what was a little bit
more difficult and one thing that you
kind of pointed out is that gaming is
just the most pure fun
thing I kids like with everything else
there's a lot of work involved there's
like metadata thumbnails it's like we
just finalized working and with with the
gaming channel so much of that pressure
is relieved one because like we've tried
to set it up in that way and not take it
too seriously because our main channel
carries a lot of the weight but also you
know we just choose a game and then we
play that game and that's a pretty good
topic but I think that one thing that I
we discussed and we noticed is that for
the gaming channel I take on all of that
responsibility and I think that you are
really enjoying I both of us really
enjoy the gaming channel but Caitlin was
like man there's like no pressure at all
with gaming everything is really chill
and like really really laid-back but at
the same time it's like I was you know
reaching out in hiring new editors and
training them up and writing procedures
and reviewing them like you know their
their rough edits and like insulating
Caitlin from a lot of like the behind
the scenes stuff uploading all the uncut
uploading all of the the main thing is
doing all the metadata doing the
playlist doing the descriptions posting
it on all the places and I think that
like I since Caitlin has a huge chunk of
extra work that I don't have which is
editing which is really amazing I mean
we talked about it all of last podcast
but that's a lot of work so I try to
take on as much of the gaming as I could
so that could be like one of the big
things I contribute and I think it's
interesting because it did allow you to
just enjoy yeah the gaming even even
more yeah which is interesting but also
it's like I love like some of the prep
work I do for gaming like all like you
know set up the the
backgrounds before we stream I'll pick
out like you know sound effects and I'll
think of a clever intro to do or like
something to start the stream off with
energy so that people watching the uncut
will have a fun experience right off the
bat so it's like I get a lot of
enjoyment out of that in the same way
that we get enjoyment out of our main
channel videos it's like we like being
creative we like going that extra mile
and I enjoy carrying that over to the
gaming channel but I do think that I
carry a lot more of the pressure for the
gaming channel like choosing the right
game is like actually a big stress for
me not a big stress but it's like will
this game be good will it lead to good
highlights will it be good for the
stream like and sometimes all it's not a
difficult job but I'll try a few
different games out and see if they
might be good for the stream and like I
put that pressure on myself it sounds a
lot like unload that much no no this is
what I love I mean I love that I can
take that on that I have that place in
our business and I take pride in that
and that it's doing well and everything
just like you like editing you like the
creative fulfillment it gives you and
you would have a hard time giving it up
not only because it's like giving up
control but also because you like being
responsible for that ya know and I kind
of identify as like one part of this
like one role that I have in our team is
like the gaming channel lead in a way
you know and like the gaming channel
wouldn't exist with either of us just
like the main channel wouldn't exist
with either of us either both of us are
100% necessary for the channel but like
you do so much more for the main channel
in the editing and even though I do more
like stuff behind the scenes like with
the CAD or 3d models or whatever
or else I mean I think that in terms of
the differential you carry a lot more of
the load for the main channel with with
edit I think one interesting thing and
this is just kind of a reflection of how
we work but I tend to work better when I
can like really get in the zone on
something and I have a really hard time
task switching I have a hard time not
task yeah you have a hard time not task
switching
so like interestingly we've kind of
fallen into some of those roles so like
the gaming stuff that's a lot of like
very individual little oddball things to
shuffle that add up to something that's
a really big responsibility and I guess
you could kind of say the same thing
about like the editing and upload and
metadata type stuff but it's more of a
focused state that you need to get into
for editing because I've done a little
bit of editing and I think that you've
talked about it too but it does seem
like you kind of need to get into the
flow of things you need to know what was
before well it's after you need to know
the whole like it's hard to edit just
half an hour at a time yeah
like to really make progress editing you
usually need to sit down for hours yeah
to really move I think another thing
that you know some of our recent
projects it may this may not have been
as big but you're very responsible for
like the structural integrity of of what
we do it's like how thick doesn't need
to be doesn't need to be supported in
certain ways what type of joinery do we
choose for this project so like yeah and
I think that we've talked about this
before some but like when we're filming
I'm always thinking about like will the
end product be good in terms of the
physical thing that we're making and the
bigger concern for you is like will the
video that we have filmed be good did we
get that transition did we say the right
thing is to move past this area and I'm
like okay what do we do next do we need
to do glue
like we'll like finishing this glue up
today
like advance are scheduled by a whole
day or it does not matter because we're
gonna have to do this tomorrow and the
logistics of things but I feel like
that's kind of even become a lot more
even on it because if you look at you
getting like I remember I used to like
I'd be wanting to capture something for
a video and you wanted to get something
done and so you start doing it and I'd
be like no no no I have to film that
stop
you know like wait wait for me and that
doesn't really happen that often
you know sometimes that happens kind of
like jokingly but they always have like
two cameras running so it's always
captured on the other camera well I
think that's just from the understanding
of each other but I guess like what I
was saying is like during the planning
both of us take kind of even
responsibility we each like bounce ideas
off of each other we're both like in
charge of that during the filming
process you are handling like making
sure we get all the Edit done or
everything we need for that and I am
handling like the logistics of the
project so even though we're doing
different things and the same thing both
of us are have like kind of equal weight
of responsibility but then once the
project is done you have to edit and I
have other things and sometimes like
well you know we've talked about it
before sometimes like we'll film a few
scenes Caitlin will go edit and then all
sand or paint or finish or what-have-you
so I think I think we are really even
and I think that we do both keep an eye
out for each other
we're like if I see you are overwhelmed
I'll take on more if you see that I am
overwhelmed you'll take on more so well
I think likewise I think like because
we've been doing this for a while now I
think like like whether it's conscious
or subconscious you kind of keep track
of like you're more conscious of the
filming and the video now and I think
that it's just like built-in with
practice and I think like maybe I'm more
than I used to be more conscious so
definitely the build or what the right
next step should be - stuff like that
yeah and we look out for each other -
it's like we don't just like
hoist all of the responsibility for our
part off to the other person both of us
are conscious of each other's main focus
also yeah I think we have both gotten
better of it about that
through practice exposure a repetition
and all of that I think yeah but I think
like the biggest unseen thing and it's
not like something we didn't fully know
and we we kind of did talk about it on
that walk recently but I think that was
like the biggest recent unknown thing
that I was taking on that you maybe
weren't yeah I was aware of yeah when it
came up cuz like I was feeling stressed
about main channel stuff and I was like
man if folio is easy the KY I think I
think the thing that you were
specifically wondering about and this is
kind of tangent thing into another topic
you're like dang like with the gaming
being so good what what is it about the
gaming that's so good that like like we
might be missing on the main channel and
how do we mix pull some of that goodness
from the gaming over to the main channel
because we're like the gaming is all
good and then like I kind of had to step
in like like I think that's because you
are protected some from the work yeah
that goes on behind the scenes and we
both we both enjoy everything that we do
but as you guys know we are optimizers
we like optimizing everything to as much
of a decree as we can so we're never
like just okay with status quo we're
always looking for how we can improve
our content our efficiency our enjoyment
out of life and everything so we always
do appreciate where we're at but we all
are we are also always trying to improve
I will say I rely on you pretty heavily
for the for like improving us in a
technical standpoint gear wise and so
yeah it's a lot of research it's
confusing
filming camera cameras doesn't filming
the same thing like like cameras audio
all the streaming stuff it's it's a lot
a night I don't really have a much
simpler setup if it was
me and I'm not saying like that I would
prefer a simpler setup I prefer what we
have now yeah that's a lot of your
knowledge coming in to make that happen
I think the crazy thing that that got to
me during all of my research and this
isn't something that we've really talked
about too much but I did so much
research about what camera to use right
now that I'm pointing at for those who
are watching on YouTube like what camera
to use for this what camera to use in
the garage
all of this stuff and what's crazy to me
is it's not just like simple specs you
know it's not like you can just like go
for the highest megapixel go for the
fastest whatever whatever you know
there's like so much that's subjective
about quality instead of just like
straight up numbers like I did some
tests like one thing they like was
actually really good and this isn't like
a plug for any store in general but like
we did go to a physical location that
had a whole bunch of cameras and we
actually brought an SD card yeah into
the store and we stuck it into all of
the cameras and then we stated what
camera it was what settings we had on
what lens was in there and we tested it
in the store and it blew our minds
because there were really expensive
cameras that had the highest megapixels
the highest everything I mean like I
don't want to throw any brands under the
bus but it was like a big name brand and
it had all of the high specs and we
looked at it
and right this doesn't look that good
it's like something about it was just
off for our aesthetics and what we were
wanting himself and it just didn't look
like the highest quality and unless you
do do a test like that where you're
filming the same person in the same
location and you can compare them it's
kind of hard to tell on that tiny screen
when you're not looking at it right next
to anything else yeah so I I'm glad I
was able to help there too even though
like I think that there is a lot of
guilt on my part when I buy something
and then later on I upgrade it or I buy
something and it's bad and it just sits
there staring at me making me feel
guilty all the time I'm thinking of a
few things in particular and I don't but
I think you are - and we don't need to
go in
I think that it is like to a certain
degree the cost of doing business like
start figuring out what is worth it to
pay the extra for and what isn't worth
it to pay the extra for and and all of
that that's true related to that I do
feel like you're often the like agent of
change
[Laughter]
again I mean I'm thinking you know I
thought of it
because of things like gear and our
setup and optimizing but I feel like you
also tend to push us and all in good
ways but like push us when it comes to
sponsors or events or you know a lot of
these things you know when we were doing
them for the first time just like except
something I was like hey Caitlin we're
doing time not really it's not that
extreme but like I have just like gotten
us into things or like like I think that
the biggest time I've just like gotten
us into things is like in person I'll
just like be very positive about
something or like get us into like a
commitment or whatever just based on
like my like intuition and just seizing
on opportunity isn't kidding it's like
that we're doing what helps get me out
of my box or when um I think that
another time that that I just like threw
us into something is when we did our
vlogging like okay let's vlog here's a
camera vlog I think we like filmed in
edit we should post it let's post it
we're posting it and like looking back
on it were they the best note did we do
it on the right channel I'm not sure did
we do it the best way I'm not sure but
like it pushed us and it evolved us in
very important ways and I'm so glad we
did it even though we may not have done
it the right way or what have you or
optimized or what have you but um who's
good practice and it helped us get to
the style of filming yeah and I think
that that um
I think that part of what's going on
behind the scenes as Caitlyn likes to be
sure about choices she wants to you know
make the right and form decision with
all of the information and like she
doesn't want to pull the trigger until
it's all known yeah but the problem with
YouTube is none of it is know and even
if it's known for one channel that
doesn't mean that it holds true for
another channel which basically means
that for us to figure out our own
channel we need to do like live
experimentation YES on our channel via
the audience you guys and we use your
your views and your shares and your
comments and all of that as input data
into this experiment that we're running
live as we film edit and everything and
I think that's one one advantage of
having a YouTube channel because we film
we edit we upload we get real-time
feedback we adjust we change we can
tweak and it's not like we're filming
for a year and then releasing a year's
worth of content it's like live back and
forth using live data I don't know yeah
so another question what was the
original question how far did we get
derail the most difficult to do that I
might or the audience might
underestimate yeah um are there any
seemingly boring or not fun tasks that
you secretly like yes and no I think the
main thing that I might secretly like is
time things that give me time to listen
to podcasts or audiobooks when I have a
really good audio book so it depends on
if I have something good something that
I secretly like yeah I mean like when
when when I have yeah I think that's
that's the only thing I can think of
right now be
so what kind of things I mean I think I
know but just so you have an answer
mainly it's like painting finishing
standing doing repeated cuts on wood
anything that's like a very easy
repetitive like task that isn't to
physically intensive and draining but
also allows me to listen to an audio
book yeah so things that like don't
require be like words part of my brain
part of your brain yeah so it's like not
emails not anything like that but like
something that's chill where I can just
listen to an audio book I think that's
that's one thing I do get enjoyment out
of that makes sense it's like like we
mentioned before cuz a lot of times like
I'll use that time to edit a lot of
those kind of like longer term but just
kind of you get in the zone and you do
the thing tasks fall on you sometimes
all I'll join in or I'll do it instead
and I do understand because it is a nice
break like when I was graphic designing
I used to have a lot more chances to
just like listen to stuff because yeah
use the words part of my brain but with
like editing or emails or yeah with a
lot of what you do you don't have extra
word parts of brain parts of brain so I
get that yeah interesting this is a side
note I've heard of people who like
listen to podcast while they edit and
I'm like wow well I could see that if
you if there are no words and you're at
it if there are no words or like if
you're just editing to music like maybe
you could listen to a podcast also and
if all you're doing is timing to edit to
music or I know I can see like a few
specific types of editing that that
might work for but not definitely not
ours because ours is now like 100
percent words 100 percent of time words
all the time and that's it's a montage
which is only like one scene out of
the whole 23 minute episode which is
basically a TV show length yeah and it's
something that we didn't consciously do
that's just like what our video length
turns out to be for reason one reason if
you could go back and actually let me
let me go to another question right this
this might be kind of repetitive so if
it is we can go to the next but what's
the biggest pressure that you put on
yourself
workwise biggest pressure I put on
myself that that like gets to me I'm
gonna add that because like there's a
lot of pressures we put on us but I feel
like we can handle I think the biggest
pressure I put on myself has always kind
of been trying to ensure that we are
gonna be happy long term with our life
with our choices with like kind of like
all of the decisions that we've made
like kind of just like are we putting
ourselves down a path that will like be
bad or like like long long long term
like are we gonna burn out are we gonna
be like are we gonna have all of our
financials in place for the long run
what if this dries up or that dries up
or we need a switch or what have you you
know it's like those are the biggest
long-term pressures that I put on myself
and those are the pressures that I've
always kind of put on myself whether
when it was just me or me and you I mean
like when when I was at my past job that
was a pressure that really really got to
me because I liked engineering to a
certain degree but the specific job I
was doing I wasn't fully crazy about it
I don't know if I was getting into the
wrong field like did I love this field
no are there other fields I might like
more maybe how do i transitioned I don't
know
so it's like those are the pressures
I've put on myself kind of not all my
life is an exaggeration but I did think
early on I think that's because of the
things we talked about my family my
relatives and stuff talked about work a
lot so I've thought about work since I
was a teenager I mean honestly like
early teens I had always thought about
work and how to prepare myself for work
what field I was gonna go into and
everything I did know engineering for
the longest time and I did like what
tell like it's so crazy I've talked
about this before but I do want to do
like making I want to like make stuff I
wanna invent stuff I don't have a big
workshop full of stuff that's why I
became an engineer I want to be able to
do all the things at any time that's
like my dream but I did think how do I
turn that into a job and engineering
seemed like by far the best choice to me
back then but yeah I always have put
pressure on myself because what you do
as a job is such a big proportion of
your life such like there's the biggest
percentage of your life more than
anything in your life is what you do for
your work yeah especially even if if
you're thinking like quite literally the
hours you spend working yeah yeah that's
like you know it's like mathematically
work sleep other things sleep probably
wins cuz you sleep your whole life oh
and you only work for 40 oh yeah so work
work and sleep and maybe might be tied
who knows but then like work and sleep
are the number one and two things you do
and then there's like family personal
hobbies yeah everything like that that
kind of like follows after in a way so
so yeah I have always put that pressure
on myself because like we've said we
like to future-proof we like to make
sure we're on the right path and the
sooner you're on the right path the this
the more secure you can be on that path
the more time you can spend on that
right path it's
you want to make that decision as early
as you can and you know I know that we
have been in very lucky places to be
able to shift our life and focus our
life in the ways that we have but but
yeah that that has been a pressure and
one thing that I have thought of before
in the past is like feeling like opening
yourself up to every possibility is good
because you you really do broaden your
horizons about what you think you might
be capable of but also opening yourself
up to like every possibility every job
every career that just like add so much
like stress and pressure because it's
like almost like an infinite I don't
know it's it's like too much there's
their studies done you know I like half
of the studies that I know are quoted
because of like Ted Radio Hour or hidden
brain so it's one of those two it's it's
a hidden brainer
Ted Radio hours and one of the podcasts
but they did a study on choices and I
think I'm mixing like two podcasts to my
brain one about choices and what about
Trader Joe's and what one was just about
choices in general and one was about
Trader Joe's and how Trader Joe's
reduced the number of choices to
increase happiness so those are two
different totally different things but
like if you go to the supermarket
wanting to get Jam if there are too many
you're unhappy if there's too few you're
unhappy if there's like if you go and
there's two choices of Jam you're like
now what's up with this this sucks I
want more than two choices if you go and
there's 100 choices that's bad too many
jams so many jams 100 is obviously too
many but like maybe 15 15 might be the
ideal number what the number is depends
on what it what you're choosing you know
and how much research you need to do
like what's the difference between this
Jam in this Jam in this chairman the
Chairman this Jam was about the jam but
but like I think that
if someone approached you and said you
need to choose between these three types
of engineering jobs choose and you just
chose and like that was the only option
to you you might be potentially more
happy than if someone came to you and
said you can choose any of these five
thousand jobs jubes yeah
by the way you should do it really quick
because the number of years you work at
your first job kind of dictates the rest
of your life hurry up you know I make
this choice without any real-world
experience yeah yeah and it is hard to
talk to like I think that there's
another Ted Radio Hour about how we
stink at predicting how happy we are
gonna be with life choices like the
human brain can process and predict
something that's like if you are
designing ice cream flavors you can
understand how like mint chocolate chip
might be a good flavor
or maybe like like strawberry and you
know other fruit flavor who knows like
strawberry vanilla tasty you can like if
even if you've never had strawberry
vanilla ice cream you can picture that
in Titan that could be good if they keep
the the flavor balance is right and
stuff what about strawberry ketchup
strawberry ketchup you know that's not
gonna be good
that's this is not tasty so you can
process those things but like if someone
approaches you and says hey do you want
to work at this company or this company
or this company or this job let's drop
this job it's like there's too many
variables there's too much there's it's
like the human brain just isn't the best
at predicting that and like they've the
studies have said that like the best way
their predict if you're gonna be happy
or not is to find someone that's similar
to you in it that that's already in that
similar situation that you're thinking
about doing and ask them but it's not
like you can go and ask every single
different type of engineer what their
experiences are and make sure that their
life profile matches with yours and then
end up in a job that has similar
co-workers to them because coworkers are
such a big part of it yeah oh sorry
that's a big I think I'm getting worked
up about these be good we're talking
about
is that like I do get worked up about
and it house trust me in the past yeah
so okay back this is an enjoyable
conversation you know it's like these
are just things that I'm very passionate
about that have thought a lot about and
I have things to say and I I just like
find myself on my soapbox preaching
that's not sure it makes sense make
sense to me but I don't know I think it
makes sense I do a follow-up that's
related so so a lot of the stress about
future happiness and future trajectory a
lot of that was felt back when you were
working like either about to go into
working a traditional job or at a
traditional job and that that's kind of
like a typical path you like get a job
working for a company and you do the
things and it's pretty known it's
relatively known like you can look at
other co-workers that have been there
longer there's usually a chain of
command that you can work your way up
there's predictable things like health
care and retirement plans yeah um but
there's much less control in what you do
like you can't just go to your boss and
be like um I'm gonna start doing this
now cool
whereas what we're doing now but you can
go to your boss and say I'm sick I
should take a day off ya can like other
co-workers cover for me for a little bit
that's true that's true but that's
that's a topic now we're in a job where
we have a lot more control even though
we do like make commitments and stuff
that we feel like we need to stick to we
are the ones that made those commitments
but we can all of a sudden say like
let's play video games for work let's
make that thing that we do so we have a
lot more control and flexibility but the
is not really a known proven path like
YouTube / content creation as a career
is very new there's not like a set path
everybody goes down there's not like a
common progression so is it more
pressure now because of the lack of
foreseeable path or the blurriness of
the foreseeable path or the you know
however you want to picture it or is
there less pressure because we have more
control over the path that we take
definitely less and I've been thinking
about why that is and I'm talking slowly
because I still AM and I'm buying myself
time but I think I think that one of the
reasons why there is so much pressure so
much time pressure about choosing the
right path is because at other like when
you're in the traditional job market you
are working at the pleasure of like your
your your company your bosses like the
like the industry if it's up or down
like whatever like they like you can be
fired at any time and there's no reason
why someone needs to hire you
so it's all you can just like switch at
any time to any job and any position get
hired to get be qualified and have
security there at any time you can be
fired and at any time you might want to
move jobs but you can't because you're
not qualified for that new job and in
order to get hired you need experience
but in order to get experience you need
to get hired so I think that the biggest
pressure like the biggest thing that
caused me pressure and unease about the
job before was the the fact that I felt
I was getting locked in like I felt like
doors were closed and opportunities were
closed
I felt like I was getting boxed in and
the longer you spend at that job the
more boxing you got I think some people
you might like find the job that you
love and you go there and you love it
and everything is good but I I wasn't I
I wasn't particularly 100% feeling good
about like my career in some ways not
that I thought it was bad and not that I
didn't enjoy the work that I did and the
people that I spent time with but I got
you know I was thinking about like 40
years or however long I might work am I
gonna be happy for 40 years and I think
the answer I was coming up with was no
but I think that the biggest change
about this is that no one can tell us
know it's like we're like we're gonna
start gaming now and it's not like
anyone has can tell us no because we're
just gonna do it you know we no one can
fire us because we employ us you know
it's like yes like if we make decisions
that are bad or if we mess up or
whatever it's like we're not gonna fire
us I don't know and at the same time you
know we do trust each other and each
other's visions and goals and like you
know you've discussed you've brought up
some interest in some other types of
videos that we might try in the future
and I got thing let's do them I'm not
sure when we're gonna fill in them and
what channel we're gonna put them on are
we gonna start a sixth channel I don't
know are they gonna go and have an
aquiline do all right we'll we'll figure
it out no one can say no though it's
just it's just us and we choose what we
want to do and no one can fire us I
think that that that's the biggest thing
like if for some reason I wanted to get
into more new product development well I
could do that and I could document that
journey on evident Caitlin or I start a
new channel and I can use the platform
that we've built up to do that it's like
the place that we like the the biggest
worry that I had was future flexibility
and future proofing our career choices
I feel like what we've stumbled into is
ultimate flexibility ultimate
reinventability ultimate power over our
own destiny and I feel like that's one
of the biggest things that I appreciate
with this as opposed to a traditional
job I mean there's a lot this is a good
job I'm wearing pajamas down here I'm
wearing capri pants
where am I not wearing any pants and
fuzzy socks funny socks are the best
good job yeah what was the question
so the question is like like since I've
been feeling this pressure my entire
life is the switch to what we've chosen
and improvement for that pressure or
worsening because of the unknowns and I
feel like in a way it's almost more
known even though there's so many
unknowns I don't know if that makes
sense it makes sense in my head there's
more control there is like so how about
this I truly believe 100% that we are
going to be working for Evan and Caitlin
for the rest of our lives and that's a
really good thing what are you gonna be
doing oh let's say that like VR explodes
there's like an improvement and
nanotechnology and VR is crazy and
everyone loves VR and like you know
projects on a VR camera so yeah and we
make VR Tube videos where we make VR DIY
and we play VR games I don't know it's
like yeah I don't know what the future
is gonna be because no one does except
for tube she goes there through the cat
portals so we're still trying to work on
her to get that information I'll have to
have her on is the next cue a guest with
her mind it'll be like an hour-long
video of the supervisor staring at you
and if you are have a high enough IQ
it's gonna be a good podcast podcast the
podcast
it'll be good bad cut yeah but I think
that the biggest stress has been the
unknown of what career am I lock myself
in and all of that and the biggest
change in that regards is I do really
feel like we're gonna be working at Evan
and Caitlin forever
what it's gonna be I don't know but I do
feel confident that we can evolve change
and grow along with whatever is
happening because no matter what life
gets kind of boring and people need
entertainment and we are making pretty
good entertainment based on the data
that our audience is providing us and I
feel I feel good about that
good questions thank you questions with
everything yeah let's move on to our
thing of the week
Wow I like Q&A episodes I feel like they
they're just like us having fun
conversations talking about things that
we were curious about to chow with each
other yeah it's like a nice excuse to
like ask questions one thing that I am
passionate about and still curious
explore our five millimeter camera
lighting audio rod accessories Wow you
don't know I like aluminum extrusions
I like modular everything and one reason
why I really like modular extrusions
like for desks and builds is it's really
easy to build something impressive rigid
strong modifiable there's all sorts of
attachments and basically 15 millimeter
rods are that for camera lighting audio
video etc etc etc and they're just
they're just really good in high quality
I mean my gosh like I feel like we could
build now they're kind of expensive for
like this DIY stuff but or maybe we just
do a project we build a whole something
with 15 millimeter aluminum rods I don't
know they're just they're really cool
standard they're standard within the
photo video audio industry and a lot of
people who build like shoulder rigs with
them filming rigs with them like all
sorts of photography construction is
made using these things because you can
like slide anything onto it and there's
all sorts of adapters and there's just
like on all of these websites that sell
camera gear there's all sorts of
accessories and it's really really neat
in particular the the reason why we
needed them is we posted some images on
patreon maybe we'll have to share this
on our our main social media now that
it's built you'll be able to see it in
the video that we put out right before
this yes when i zoom in
on ya when i zoom in on the the tripod
with the camera you'll see it for a
moment there but maybe we'll post a
photo along with it because I think it's
interesting but we needed to build a
really secure platform that could hold
our camera and our whole audio recording
jig that we could take off and add on
and move around level it a two-headed
tripod now thanks to thanks to these
things so our tripod if you picture it
instead of just at the top of the tripod
there's a camera at the top there's a
horizontal beam essentially with the
camera being one head and the audio
bundle yeah but it's like 14 inches wide
on top of a tripod and the whole thing
is rigidly locked on there like when we
take the SD card in and out the whole
thing doesn't go wah-wah-wah it's like
very rigid which is a lot of money it's
a lot of investment yeah so I think
that's my thing of the week because it's
my new modular building material
obsession yes they're also aluminum
extrusions but they're aluminum
extrusions in a different form okay so
my thing of the week when did this video
even come out we've been it's not it's
not a new video we found a new content
creator and we've been on a kick just
watching okay so we've been watching a
lot of Danny Gonzales he's not a new
content creator we just hadn't you know
you're always like running across
channels on YouTube and you're like wow
this channel has like a few million subs
and like the content is good how do I
not know about this person until right
now yeah so that happened with Danny
Gonzalez um and he does a lot of funny
like commentary type videos on you know
like social media type stuff or just
like he's very funny yeah and there are
some cursing so maybe don't watch with
we love his content it's it's very
entertaining
I thought for my thinking the week I
would recommend one of my favorite
videos of his that we've watched
recently and it actually is a pretty
recent video the video is I changed my
identity on Instagram and got away with
it kind of and so good he basically and
I had heard about this guy that he like
NPR one of our podcasts yeah there's
there's this guy called Paul Zimmer who
I think was it on Tik Tok or Instagram
anyways he basically like he had some
faux paws kind of went dark on social
media and then came back and was like
hey this other person by a different
name is like the younger hotter version
of me you should all go follow him and
it was just him it was just him with a
different name him with a different name
and he was he was pretending to be a
different person on this other profile
said he could escape all the controversy
said is like since I think this guy is
so cool I'm just gonna hand over my
Instagram and all my social media
accounts to him so he I kept his
followers so like so Danny's video is
kind of a about what this guy did but he
tried doing it himself to see like would
this even be possible cuz everyone
called out this this dude yeah he didn't
try to change anything so in Danny's
video he tried to actually like really
try to use photos of himself and
convince his audience that it was a
different and the goal is slightly
modified but the goal was to like gain
this fake person 10,000 subscribers by
the end of the experiment so I won't
tell you how it turned out but it was
very interesting to watch it was yeah so
we'll have a link to that and a link to
I mean I don't know how you want to link
to the 15 millimeter odds autos lists a
few different accessories that I liked
and you can google the rest yeah alright
guys well thanks so much for joining us
in today's podcast we really appreciate
you guys tuning in the week after week
and we really appreciate those five-star
reviews that you've already left I'm
sure I trust you you've already left
them really appreciate you and sharing
it with your friends and family or
people you think my like it oh that's
all I ask
okay here's good
[Music]